想学习怎么争取孩子抚养权的朋友，
来来来啊，
咱们今天系统的捋一捋抚养权的问题。
第5个方向咱们得说出来，
怎么拆对方的台，
就是要让法官知道对方不适合带孩子，
对方如果有犯罪记录，
坐牢了，
判决书被行政拘留过，
那么就是杀手锏的证据，
对方如果有家庭暴力，
那么出警纪律也赶紧要交上去。
如果对方有什么恶习，
比如酗酒，
赌博，
吸什么什么啥的也能当成证据，
对方如果虐待孩子，
家暴孩子有视频记录，
那就更好了。
包括对方如果在聊天的过程当中说过不想要孩子的，
这样的证据也可以提交。
还有如果对方平时在跟你聊天的时候非常的低俗，
说脏话，
这个也能证明对方有人品，
不适合带小孩儿，
对方沉迷于网络打游戏，
打赏擦边女主播，
看色情直播，
这些也可以作为证据去提交，
对方原生家庭情惯差，
年天成度下环境脏乱差，
你也要多留心，
多拍照，
对方的父母如果年纪大，
身体不好，
不能照顾孩子，
还有可能需要这个孩子反过来照顾他们，
那这个你也要向法官去说明，
对方如果本人有严重能担精神类疾病，
咱们就把。
他的就诊的记录偷偷保存下来，
作为证据去提交。
对方的父母如果长期在老家，
没有时间帮他照顾孩子，
咱们也得找到证据，
比如说有聊天的记录，
或者说有父母长期在老家生活的一些照片、
视频，
那证明她如果出差了，
她如果下班了，
她如果下班晚了，
是没有人来帮助她带小孩的。
对方父母如果有让人受不了的一些举动，
比如说现实生活中有老公公猥亵儿媳妇儿，
甚至猥亵儿童这方面的，
如果你有证据，
有视频，
也赶紧提交。
总之咱们得把能想到的证据都找出来，
整理好，
交上去。
在搜集证据的过程当中，
我们要细致入微，
不放过任何一个可能对争取抚养权有利的细节，
比如孩子日常生活的习惯的记录能体现出来，
我们对孩子的生活起居的精心照顾，
孩子跟我们共同参加活动的照片和视频，
展示出亲子之间的深厚的情感纽带。
还有就是孩子教育这方面，
我们为孩子选择的学校环境怎么样，
口碑好不好，
参与的课外活动丰富丰富，
老师的资质怎么样，
这些也能有力的证明我们在为孩子的未来积极的谋划。
至于哪个证据会打动法官，
决定着判决的走向，
咱们谁也摸。
不准，
毕竟法官他也是人，
他有自己的生活经历，
有自己的喜好，
有自己的累点和价值观，
但这些并不意味着我们只能天天一命，
我们要以客观的、
真实的、
全面的态度去呈现这个证据，
让法官能够在众多的角度去了解孩子的生活状况以及我们对孩子的关爱程度。
法官在审理这样一个案件时，
通常会综合考虑各种因素，
比如孩子的年龄、
性别、
健康状况、
生活环境、
教育需求等等等等，
我们要针对这些因素有的放矢的准备证据，
提高我们争取孩子抚养权的胜算。
咱们把该做的都做了，
万一结果不如人意，
心里也能够不愧对孩子，
不责难自己。
这话听上去让人很难以接受，
但现实生活中，
真正一心一意对孩子好的人，
最后没有占到抚养权的一抓一大把。
这可能是因为法律考量是多方面的，
不仅仅取决于我们对孩子的爱，
有的时候对方可能在经济实用，
居住条件，
社会资源等方面更有优势。
然而我们不能因此气馁或者放弃孩子，
放弃自己，
生活还得继续，
日子还得过。
我们要学会调整心态，
可以通过跟朋友，
跟家人的交流，
寻求他们的支。
知识和理解，
也可以参加一些心理辅导课程，
帮助我们缓解压力和焦虑。
同时我们也要继续关注孩子的成长，
跟孩子保持良好的沟通和互动，
即使不能时刻陪伴在孩子身边，
我们也可以通过电话、
视频各种各样的方式让孩子感受到我们的爱。
关键是等孩子满8周岁，
我们还可以再努力一下，
看能不能变更孩子的抚养权。
如果孩子铁了心的想要跟你过，
那么你还有机会啊。
在孩子成长过程当中，
我们要不断的跟孩子去建立深厚的感情基础，
尊重孩子的想法和感受，
倾听他们的心声，
让孩子知道我们永远是他最坚实的后盾。
当孩子满8周岁后，
他们的意愿在抚养权变更中会起到重要的作用。
我们要积极的跟孩子去沟通，
了解他的想法，
并且向他们表达我们对他的爱和关心，
同时我们也要准备好充分的证据证明我们有能力给孩子提供更好的生活和教育环境。
最后，
不管是否能够争取到孩子的抚养权，
咱们都好好的珍惜跟孩子相处的每一天。
孩子的成长是如此的迅速，
每一个瞬间都值得我们去珍惜，
无论是一起度过的欢乐时光，
还是。
共同面对的困难时刻，
都将成为我们和孩子之间宝贵的回忆。
我们可以一继续看电影、
读书、
做手工等等，
让孩子感受到我们的陪伴和爱。
即使在抚养权的争夺过程当中，
我们也要以孩子的利益和心理健康为重，
不去诋毁、
贬低、
丑化、
污蔑配偶一方，
不去逼孩子的表态，
不利用孩子作为工具，
避免在孩子心里种下不健康的种子。
好了，
今天就我到到这儿，
希望对大家有帮助，
愿每一个为了孩子抚养权而努力的人都能够保持坚定的信心和积极的态度。
父母之爱子，
则谓之寄生源，
无论结果如何，
我们都相信爱永远是孩子成长中最强大的力量。